this is not an ordinary bike ride
through town this is not an ordinary
bike it doesn't have just one back wheel
but to a net both tiny and forget about
the saddle this is not about comfort you
have to use your whole body to ride a
half bike and it takes a bit of practice
[Music]
the stock bike is an omission it's a
cross between a bike and a skateboard
but when you ride it it's a completely
different feeling it's a whole new
experience because and against noia fr
hi Micah Kluger went to Sofia in
Bulgaria to meet the inventors of the
half bike so far all half bikes are made
in this workshop and sent around the
world mainly to the US a half by costs
500 euros they're easy to fold up which
is great for people who live in big
cities the designers are originally
architects who love to invent things I
usually like to simplify things to an
extreme so I started to think over bike
which is very minimalistic very very
compact and very light and then the idea
from for the standing by key game so I
wanted to create something like unicycle
but not for for everybody the prototypes
consisted of half a bike and a mini back
wheel many attempts featuring too many
wheels followed but they all lack
stability and balance the breakthrough
came when they started using to
skateboard wheels and a structure made
of aluminium and wood then the back
wheels got bigger and thicker
[Music]
the designers raised over seventy
thousand euros for their first 100
models on the kickstart a crowdfunding
platform in 2014 the year after they
launched another campaign to raise nine
hundred thousand euros for two thousand
bikes and since then it's been simply
non-stop our reporter first learnt the
ropes
the designers explained that she could
only brake using the back wheels and
that there were three gears yes they
pointed out that the handlebar can't be
twisted you have to shift your weight to
go around the corner then it was time to
put the theory to the test the bike will
start to curl either direction I can try
to keep it in a straight line and try to
balance in the handlebar and try to be
as relaxed as possible at first she
wasn't at all relaxed
she thought she wouldn't make it at all
it was a bit rough to begin with
[Music]
but she got the hang of it after ten
minutes although she didn't dare try the
tougher courses meeting those two more
experienced half bike riders
[Music]
she practiced a little more before
venturing out into the world since there
are few cycle paths in Sofia she
preferred to hone her skills in the park
before confronting the urban jungle she
was able to go straight quite fast but
it took a while to master turns then she
decided to see if others were quicker at
learning than she was
[Music]
it seems that hardly anyone can really
ride a half bike without a bit of
practice but those who master it can
sometimes ride too at the same time
[Music]
but impotency to see other like it looks
easy but it really isn't it takes quite
a lot of effort and every muscle is
needed you have to be quite fit to ride
a half bike but if you are then it's
really quite good fun then that master's
course pass while mica was having fun
and beginning to master riding the half
bike the team in Sofia was already
working on new ideas since there are
many ways of reinventing the wheel
[Music]